wir brauchen keine staatsreligion in der
fotomontage in dem grünen gewand das
soll ein bisschen an moses erinnern und
da hat die initiative neue soziale
marktwirtschaft jetzt nicht zehn gebote
sondern zehn verbote darauf gedruckt die
sie den grünen beziehungsweise ihrer
kanzlerkandidaten in den mund gelegt hat
herr wissing haben sie über das plakat
gelacht oder den kopf geschüttelt
ich habe darüber geschmunzelt aber ich
kann nachvollziehen dass die thesen der
grünen die menschen provozieren
hier steht ja ganz offensichtlich einen
linksruck an
die grünen bereiten ein linksruck vor
frau berg hat sich ja auch nicht auf die
frage ein gelassen ob sie denn bereit es
sich von der linken zur kanzlerin wählen
zu lassen
und das spricht ja bände und dass dann
eine initiative neue soziale
marktwirtschaft die sich um die
marktwirtschaft bemüht auch provoziert
und dann richtig kräftig einsteigt das
ist für mich nachvollziehbar kennt diese
initiative in der tat auch weil sie
häufig auf uns abzielt wir haben das
zuletzt erlebt als es um rente gegen
olaf scholz hat das abgekriegt und das
muss man schon klar benennen da sind
finanziert dahinter die wollen nicht
dass es soziale verbesserungen gibt die
wollen nicht dass politik für rentner
für arbeitnehmer politik des sozialen
miteinanders gemacht wird werde genau
mit dabei ist da gehe ich nicht
hinterher in der tat wir haben wahlkampf
da gibt es heftige auseinandersetzungen
aber man muss dann noch klar benennen
worum es geht und noch mal da sind
menschen die haben kein interesse dass
es soziale verbesserungen gibt die hand
kein interesse daran dass der staat an
das funktioniert das muss man hinnehmen
in wahlkampfzeiten man kann das aber
auch klar und deutlich benennen ich
glaube das problem ist doch
offensichtlich ein anderes dass es
inzwischen viele menschen gibt die in
deutschland doch sorge haben sorge haben
dass die grünen das wahrmachen was auch
vor allem an gerade noch mal gesagt hat
nämlich deutschland umzubauen und zwar
sehr fundamental und da zeigt sich
eigentlich etwas anderes dass die grünen
seit jahren auf einem feldzug sind gegen
auto mobilität generell gegen mobilität
und dieses momentum konnten sie nie
ablegen